We begin in Davenport, Iowa, this hour.
Words were mentioned.
Any minute now,
we are expecting to hear
from authorities.
This as rescue teams continue
to search for anyone who may be missing
following a six story apartment buildings
partial collapse.
At least seven people
we know have been rescued.
That collapse happening on Sunday.
Authorities, though,
are warning of the building's instability
this morning.
CNN's Adrian Broad is joining us live.
So the damage we see in
those pictures is really something,
which means I would imagine
this is a very delicate rescue effort.
What more do we know
about those efforts
and the number of people
who remain unaccounted for?
Adrian
Well, Erica, good morning to you.
We still do not know
how many people are missing.
We do know
authorities were able to rescue
at least seven people.
And as you mentioned,
we're standing by
to get an update from authorities
regarding the search and rescue efforts
that are still underway
after this, if you see on your screen.
It's a partial apartment collapse
in Davenport, Iowa.
We did hear from the fire chief, Mark
Karl, Steve.
He says this is going to be
a long, lengthy process and he says it's
going to take us a while
to get this taken care of.
Overnight, crews worked,
as you mentioned.
This is a delicate process,
but the big concern right now
is the stability of the structure.
And crews
are working to
see if anyone is under the debris
there in downtown Davenport, Iowa Erica.
So we also know the city Adrian,
had ordered the building owners
to make some upgrades.
So we know more about those upgrades
this morning.
So here's a little
what we know
during that news conference
where the fire chief
addressed members of the media.
We were told
the building owners
did have permits in place
for, quote, repairs
to some of the exterior walls.
And it appears
that is where the work on
this apartment was taking place.
But here's
something that is telling before
this partial collapse.
Tenants of the building
voiced and expressed their concern,
calling the city quote,
numerous times for things.
And these repairs to the building
were ordered by the city.
So as you can imagine, as crews
are there right
now, we're taking a look
at some live pictures.
You see them looking.
We they're looking up.
You see debris there.
They're kind of
sifting through the debris.
And even as they were searching
through the night,
we're told
some of the debris was falling.
So I can't underscore enough
that big concern,
not only for folks
who may be trapped there,
but this crew
that is working to find anyone
who was inside
the integrity of the building,
the stability of this structure Erica.
Adrian brought us.
Appreciate the updates
and we'll continue to check in with you.
Thank you.
Yesterday afternoon, landmark apartments
downtown Davenport partially collapsed.
Dumpster fire, police and poor
public works immediately
responded to the scene
to import crews as well as partners
from assisting agencies from across
the state have been working
throughout the night.
Let's say many agencies here in a moment.
First and foremost, my heart
and certainly
the community's heart
goes out to those
have been impacted by the
unimaginable tragedy
and that we saw yesterday.
Communities here to support them
in any way we can
for those in the community
that are looking to assist victims.
The Red Cross is coordinating
community response for the victims.
One 800 Red Cross one 800 Red Cross.
I want to thank our numerous partners.
And again, I'll list them.
But I want to take a special attention
to our fire
whose folks immediately
went into that building
no concern about themselves.
Only the concern was
can they assist and help anybody
to get them out
and to assist anybody in that building.
That was their focus
The medic folks,
the Genesis folks,
I mean, are literally in an
unsafe building trying to assist
So.
Well, and
again, I
thank the numerous partners
I read that assisted
some who are remaining on the scene
as we speak currently
When something like this happens
here, when tragedy strikes,
our responders immediately
do their work and do their job.
And I can't thank them enough.
Our community
response, the outpouring of support,
the outpouring of offers
of assistance at the state level,
the county level, the community level.
Other cities
I can't say enough about that
in the
in the magnitude of
of our work with our partners.
So just a quick list Davenport Fire.
Davenport Police. Denver Public Works.
Davenport Development.
Neighborhood Services.
Bettendorf Fire.
Moline Fire. Rock Island Fire.
Rock Island. Arsenal Fire. Department.
Iowa Task Force One
who are still there today.
Mabus 43 and 39.
Multiple agencies involved with them.
Orthopedic specialists Genesis Hospitals
and doctors. Med Force.
Scott County Emergency
Emergency Management.
Scott County Emergency Communications.
Scott County Gas.
Scott County Health Department.
Bettendorf Police. Scott County Sheriff.
Iowa State Patrol.
American Red Cross
Sheriff Hattori Mid-American.
Iowa.
American Valley Construction.
All coming with the sole purpose of
How can I help?
How can I assist in how can I get
the victims taken care
if you don't hear anything else from me?
Take it that
the sole focus of everybody on scene.
How can I help?
How can I get the victims
how can I take care of them
irrespective of their personal safety?
So I'm going to turn it over to
the fire chief
Chief Carlson for statements.
Then I'll come back up for questions.
Chief Baker Square
as mayor, stated.
My name is Mike Carlton.
I am the Davenport Fire Chief.
Just give you an update
from our last briefing that we had
throughout the night.
Our rescue operations have continued.
We were able to locate one victim
and we are able to
extract them from the building
that was done
with a lot of the teamwork and partners
that the mayor
actually talked about here
a few minutes ago.
Iowa Task Force One.
The Cedar Rapids Division
arrived overnight
and they began additional search
and rescue operations
assisted by K-9 units.
They've been working
throughout the night,
and they are still on scene at this time.
We've had multiple structural engineers
have been onsite throughout the night
to provide technical guidance
for for a rescue effort.
We are currently finishing
the rescue phase of our operation
and we will
and soon
it will become a recovery operation.
If anyone's concerned about
a possible missing
loved one or unknown
person, please
contact 911 with this information
at this time.
The building is structurally unsound
as posing a risk to responders.
We are actively working
for the best course of
action for the building.
We have
a continued concern
for the stability of the building,
and we continue to ask the public
to avoid the area.
All right.
So if you have a question,
please raise your hand up point two
and then we'll go. Sir.
Mr. Mayor, a couple of things.
Number one, are there.
What are the things being considered
right now
that maybe created
or caused this collapse?
The person who was rescued.
Anything about their condition
and those K-9 dogs,
the persons at the hospital.
At the hospital. The dogs are on scene.
Okay.
Can you tell us about the canine dogs?
Explain to us
I know it's obvious, but explain to us
what exactly they're looking for.
And the clock is ticking for
how important? Yes.
These canine
dogs are specialized
and they're specialized
in multiple different functions.
Some are cadaver
dogs, some search out
life rescue individuals.
That may be trapped.
They've been working.
I think we are told
the six
dogs have been on scene
and they've been doing different shifts,
working through the operations.
This has all been a coordinated effort
through the Task Force One,
the Cedar Rapids Division,
and it's been there.
Crews
have kind of managed that aspect
of the recovery or the rescue.
How important is it to make sure
we've been doing everything
we can to move as fast
and as efficiently as we can
throughout the process?